Hello everybody, it's Dr. Kevin Connors again for Connors Clinic Live and today we have a very special guest
who is a long time hero of mine. So I told him before this interview of that, I'm a little star-strong
because when I first graduated as a chiropractor back in 1986, I read a lot about this guest here, Dr.
Ralph Moss and he literally was my hero, he was one of the only people that was maybe in maybe not
an opposing medical camp per se, like not an atropath or not a chiropractor so therefore they're
against the medical profession. But he was a Ph.D. researcher, scientist, scientific writer. I mean,
your list of accolades goes on and on and on. So we're going to just jump in. You gave me the
inspiration to to continue what I feel like was God's leading me to help people from an alternative
perspective with cancer. You gave me the courage to stand up when it can be daunting sometimes.
So how did you get into looking at other forms of cancer treatment other than standards of care?
Yeah, I had no intention of doing that and I actually learned about a job opening at
Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center in the Public Affairs Department and I was a writer,
I wanted to be a writer, I wanted to be able to write for a living, it was a passion of mine from
childhood, you know, pretty early on and I loved writing, publishing, seeing what I wrote in print
and so forth. So I applied for the job, it was completely far fetched in a way because I had just
gotten my Ph.D. from Stanford in classics but in the course of the seven years that it took me
to get the Ph.D., I realized that I didn't want to teach Latin and Greek for the rest of my life.
I had done it, I taught at University of California and I was then teaching at Hunter College in New York
but two things, one is that I wanted to do something more meaningful and that's not the right word
but more socially conscious with my career and I was interested in science but I was interested in it,
not in doing it but in observing it, thinking about it, writing about it, writing about the scientist,
all that appeal to me and I got the job and my spiel basically was, well, I don't know
anything about science so therefore I'm just like the people you're trying to reach and there was
a little truth to that, it was actually the same thing that Gerald Peel was sort of the founder of
this science writing profession in America, he used that same spiel to get a job with
a time magazine, I think it was, good you vanity student and can look at science from as an
outsider from the outsider's perspective so it's a powerful combination if you have the ability to
understand what scientists are doing but you retain your beginner's mind or your late person's mind,
it's you know you're not in the game but you're you're closely observing the game and even though
I have now gone on and co-written and co-authored some I don't know 30 or 35 scientific articles but I'm
not a scientist, I'm really I'm just sort of the the person observing and judging and criticizing
what other people are doing so that's a unique position to have I think in the cancer field.
And it does make it more appealing to the reader when they're not here, whether they're not
maybe your filter it out the mumbo jumbo that the language of the scientist and it is a layman's
terms where they can feel like that it's better communicating to them they can understand.
Right and all science writers do that I think the difference between me and most science writers is
I have I have the freedom to criticize not that I'm always criticizing but I have the freedom if I see
something that seems wrong or or um not logical or that'll miss critical pieces of information I can
say that and nobody can stop me from saying that because other than a short stint that I I put
in for three years as a senior medical editor at a at a publishing company medical legal publishing
company I've basically been freelance since 1980 since you're actually since the end of 77 and that's
given me the the the freedom to be able to say what I want and then of course having a wonderful family
my wife we've been together we started dating just this week in 1959 my my six we went out of my
16th birthday and my children my son and my daughter and their spouses and my grandchildren now so
you know I've had this amazing support group my wife made it possible for me to financially
to be able to be a freelance writer because as I'm sure you're aware and as your listeners are where
it's a very up and up up and down type of profession it's not a not a stable income by any means I mean
uh if you're especially if you're dependent on selling articles to magazines and newspapers mostly though
I've published my own things I mean I went up until the when was it maybe in 1992 we published our
own first time we ever published our own book Cancer Therapy which was a guide to 102 different
non-conventional cancer treatments that that actually did very well it was just the right moment
in the history of publishing to be able to put out your own book and then have it be picked up by
Barnes & Noble and and then Amazon and so forth so that was very doable and now we have our most
reports which are diagnosis specific reports on about 40 different cancer diagnoses which covers about
95% of all the cancer cases in the United States and other countries and we sell these on our website
mostreports.com that's how that and I also do phone consultations for cancer patients pretty much
every day I'll do what try to do one and sometimes I you know the demand is so much I have to do too
a day which is you know pretty pretty time consuming but this is how we pay how we pay the bills
basically we we help the individual cancer patient in this very difficult moment in their life which
trying to decide on what's the best treatment should they take the conventional treatment if they do
what could they do alongside it in order to make the outcome better or the side effects you know less
severe and or should they be thinking about alternatives and if they're thinking about alternatives
what's real and what's phony what who's real and who's phony and you know I've had 45 46 years now
to think about this and to examine this and and the luxury and the leisure to go all around the world
to look anywhere in the world that I wanted to and and for instance I I made a first site visit to a
clinic in 1976 it was it was a clinic in Tijuana, Mexico that was using leotrol and some other
controversial treatments and then in the not starting in the 90s I started going to Germany pretty
much every year and I made 18 trips to Germany to study the medical system there and the the use
of complementary medicine and also going then expanding out from there to other European destinations
and then finally to China I went to to China twice and you know other other many other places
to try to see what other people were doing and what was the validation for what they were doing
and was this a place that an American or an English-speaking person would possibly want to go to
for treatment and it was a it's been a fascinating journey and some of that you can capture some
of the feeling of that wasn't the trip that I took it was a trip that my grandson Jacob took
about a year or so ago to we sort of sent him to different clinics in Europe and then in the
United States to talk to the doctors there about immunotherapy immunotherapy and we produced
he produced a film for the immunotherapy the battle within and I give you a plug for that film because
that's on your website available for people to watch an excellent production yeah thank you
just a fantastic film so I really enjoyed getting on there and it's a homemade movie basically I
mean Jacob hadn't made a movie before he had he had some experience with sort of collateral fields
to that but it wasn't really filmmaking so this was his introduction he and his
girlfriend slash Beyonce I'm not sure which which one is the right term at the moment but anyway
they went to Europe for our more supports and then they introduced they interviewed all these people
but for me although I totally um you know totally was involved in what all these people were saying
but the real hero of the film was somebody who died about 80 years ago and that's William
Becoley and William Becoley is one of my heroes and one of my inspirations um in life because um he
was really the first and who invented who first dared to use the immune system to cure cancer
and that's a that was an extremely um an extremely controversial statement I mean if you said that to
anybody any oncologist um 20 years ago I mean they you would have branded yourself as a complete quack
by by doing that today it's a commonplace you see it all over the place William Becoley the
grandfather or the father of cancer immunotherapy and his progeny if you will intellectual progeny
Jim Alice and was awarded the Nobel Prize in 2018 and of course he wanted for his own accomplishments
but on another level and I think I brought this out in the film this was really a prize that went
not just to him but to his mentor Lloyd old and to Lloyd old and Helen man to our Helen
coley not sent to Helen coley not as mentor for father William Becoley so there is a line of descent
amazingly a line of descent within the field of cancer immunotherapy straight from William Becoley
and what happened in the 1890s to Jim Allison and the modern day immune checkpoint inhibitor therapy
that he invented and I tried to bring this out he wouldn't come out with a you know I interviewed him
for an hour um that was very good interviewing we have that interviews on YouTube but he never
came out and said yes you're right I am the intellectual heir to William Becoley it was all like
you know yeah but he didn't say this and he didn't say that and so forth but to me it was obvious
and I wanted to tell that story and that's the way I see it I mean I see I studied history look I
mean that's what classics is you're deeply immersed in things that happened 25 hundred years ago
and and so to me it was the historical connection with William Becoley was the very very strong point
and I want I can't still to this day wrap my head around a situation where a person let's say an
oncologist knows and acknowledges that this man William Becoley cured advanced cancers 100 and 110
and 120 years ago using a very simple treatment um a mixture of two bacteria that had been killed
he killed and then was injected into the patient and they kept that up for a number of months and the
net result was that hundreds of people were cured of advanced cancers by him doing this and I'm
gonna interrupt you for a second for some for listeners that made our yeah remember this story
that was called he called that Cole's toxins yeah um and the purpose was to basically inject an
attenuated bacteria that um would stimulate an immune response and his whole idea uh and correct
if I'm wrong was if he could just stimulate a hyper immune response to something the immune system
no longer would have to kill it would then turn its focus on other things in the body
that maybe need to be killed like cancer and he was right and it worked and uh now let's
you continue so Cole yeah well but I mean it's it was attenuated but it was also killed
bacteria because he had started out using live bacteria and some people got very sick some nurses and
so that was not yeah was not tenable to use an infectious agent but it what the body sees a killed
bacteria like a massive infection it's sort of like a false alarm sure that's that brings out the entire
you know fly you know do it add to that it's still the antigen of the bacteria is is the same thing
so the body sees it as a menace and goes after it and so it's in a way like sort of like a vaccination
the interesting thing is that coley and I I have a double double triple check this but Jim
Allison told me that coley never actually explicitly made the connection to the immune system which
is interesting coley just knew from a very very special case we have a picture of the man that
who was that case we even know what his name was and uh this man had had had four operations for
head and neck cancer and it had occurred and then he spontaneously developed a skin disease called
erasipolis and the cancer either erasipolis went away eventually and the cancer went away
never occurred or it didn't occur the time that coley looked for him and coley went all over
Manhattan and he finally found this guy was a German immigrant and mr. Stein his name was and
brought it back to his mentor at New York hospital and man was free of cancers that was where he got
the idea that they knew that erasipolis was caused by strep bacteria and then he started to give
under the Aegis of Memorial Hospital which now memorials lungedering to give that as a treatment
but all he knew was erasipolis which was a horrible skin disease really but you don't
see much of it because it's cured with antibiotics now but it's a horrible thing and uh if you
got that horrible thing and you survived and you had cancer there's a good chance your cancer was
going to go away I'm not I'm not suggesting that your listeners try to pick up a case of erasipolis
it wouldn't be it's pretty nasty in any way it'd be cured with antibiotics but the principal
was there he didn't really understand it honestly he was a surgeon he was a practical man he was
an extremely busy man I had a number of other outstanding careers in different kinds of surgery
but he but he was able to do this thing he was able to cure people but it remained for his daughter
who was not a science not bred without you know educated as a scientist to turn her attention to
after he died to what it was that made him so unique they coley so unique and what it was about the
treatment what made the treatment successful and that was a tremendous achievement and basically
it took her 35 to 40 years of research into his cases is she assembled all all of his cases that
you she could find all the cases of people who had been treated with the coley's toxins and all the
people who had spontaneously developed what would you say fevers and infections and what cancer
patients and what happened to them and these were put into monograph the most boring format that you
could imagine she did never sensationalize you know she did everything by the book because she was the
daughter of a famous memorial hospital surgeon and she desperately wanted to have acceptance by the
medical establishment but she got a little bit of that but did not she didn't anticipate that her
did whatever her her intellectual heirs Jamalison was going to win the Nobel Prize that would have been
very very satisfying to her I knew her quite well that's right well she just put her case studies
together absolutely and that is research unfortunately that has been much ignored by the medical
profession oh I always and and it's all just honored in the breach or whatever they say it's
it's just given lip service and nobody takes it seriously and the books are actually I have a set
but the books are in danger of actually disappearing with the face of the earth there's there's only a few
copies left um I know a couple of people who have copies but this is a this is why I wanted to make the
film because I could not in good conscience just go on knowing that there was a cure for various you
know people with cancer that existed and not shout that from the rooftops it's just unconscionable but
it you know so I help everybody will come to our website which is most reports.com and right up at the
front we put the link to the film it's free and and then also my latest book it cancer incorporated
is also available in in the electronic version it's free and then you could also buy a print version
for not very much money so I would say you know we're trying to get the message out here and we don't
want to let we have to course we have to make a living too but we're not we don't want to let the
the practical practical practical considerations get in the way of this tremendous social duty
that we have to let the world know what has actually happened these of the the you know what we
used to call alternative medicine and so forth. Well that's why I respected you for all these years
it's just that you you've lived from your heart and and felt like there was a greater responsibility
than the dollar and you see I write a lot about publication bias in my book and how
it's difficult to even trust studies and drugs today because they might put it out for a study
to 12 universities yeah they only published the two that came back positive um it's just
it's the would you say you better independent author I don't know how many there are out there that
exist anymore um the people are bought and sold like commodities um you know yes granted we everybody
has to pay their bills but then that misinformation takes place and um it's it's very difficult for
people to really get at the truth to dig to get at the truth who we see that today to even work
whatever so well you know I started out I published with very good publishing companies um
Grove Press was my first publisher I was very proud to be associated with them and then I
published with Harper Collins with with dial when I had a contract that I didn't publish with them
but with um with uh uh pentham with uh many other the double day so I you know I did all those things
but at a certain point I realized that I just didn't fit in and it wasn't that the that the editors
were particularly prejudiced for against it just that it's not commercial what I do it's um you know if
you want to do something commercially successful you have to hype something basically I mean the days
of being able to get you know really vigorous sales with a critique of the establishment went out um
um started to go down in the 1980s and by about 1990 it was pretty much dead you couldn't uh you
know uh you could not really get any traction with that both the public taste changed and the
the there was more consolidation and publish and the editors seem to be more conservative so 1980
would I publish cancer industry that was sort of the high point and you had other people who were
critics of quite a few of the cancer establishment you had some pretty high level people like Sam
Epstein who wrote the politics of cancer. Mandelson was another one John Baylor who had been editor in
chief of the journal of the National Cancer Institute um yeah I mean I could you know if I thought about it
I could name half a dozen other people many other people who were doing similar things and there's some
other very talented science writers who got into it and then just fell by the wayside for
for one reason you know usually for some personal reason and it had stopped being commercially viable
you know so it kind of left left the field to me and I just am obsessed so you know it's not a fair
it's not a fair competition because I'm literally let's say I was I was up from three to five this
morning revising my more supports I mean any I'm obsessed I any moment that I get that I can work on
my my writing and my you know this is now voluminous body of of work that I've done about the cancer
topic I'll do and I can what look at myself and say that guy's crazy but you know at least I have
enough distance but it's a good crazy you know I love you so much thank you yeah it's like I've
published all of my stuff self-published because I was able to wait so right like you know publisher's
not gonna let you do that quite so yeah well I just thank you for this interview I thank you for
telling me you know tell it our listeners a little bit about you um as I told my staff I was
interviewing here I was literally like I said Starstruck and and I want more people to continue to
know what you do in this age of cancel culture um uh we got to get the word out and the truth out
so people can hear these things from an unbiased point of view like yours it's it's great um just
given people opinion and some facts and some data that they can chew on and help make help them
be able to make the best choice possible for the health care because to me that's what it's all about
that's all it is about people you'd be able to make their own choice and not be forced to do something
they don't want to do right and I at one time in the 90s you know I had the dream of being able to
sort of help direct government policy to make the to make this happen um it was not possible
we we had we formed the office of alternative medicine uh with two million dollar uh allotment
from the congress for thanks to senator hark and um and it's now the national center for complement
your integrative health they got rid of that alter that a word the alternative word um but
there was a split within the 18 person uh panel that i was on i was on on the alternative medicine
program advisory council and the split was over direction of course whether to take the most
controversial things uh that the public was most interested in and evaluate those things
fairly honestly without prejudice and let the chips fall with a may that was my position our
position i was not was not alone in this we had about oh out of the 18 we probably had um six or
seven of the 18 who were solidly behind that proposal and that wasn't mostly because of me it's
mostly because of burglary bedel who was a six term congressman from Iowa who was highly supportive
of that position and then you have the other people who um whatever the reason uh believe that
what should happen is the money there wasn't much money at that point but whatever money there was
should go to the most prestigious university you could find to do studies that were
peripheral to the controversial treatments and just sort of nibble around the edges and let the field
get established and in time those other you know controversial things could be studied
well we both were right in the sense that yes it grew to uh i think it's a 144 million dollars uh which
is a nice piece chuck a change uh for studying alternative complementary medicine but the studies
of the controversial treatments never happened in other words what was agitating the public at that time
virgin skis treatment in texas the ontinia plaston's lateral or so-called vitamin B-17 the
Burton method in the Bahamas um a intravenous vitamin C all these things that were enormously
interesting to the public were completely off limits in terms of the academic medical establishment
and what they wanted to do is what came to pass and in other words they set up a uh alternative
complementary or integrative section at memorial slantettering my old alma mater and at Harvard and
and all the other pretty much across the country the more established and more prestigious the more likely
they were to set up a complement and in those places basically the whole this enormous field at 102
different treatments i talked about in in cancer therapy shrank down kept shrinking shrinking shrinking until
basically became acupuncture and massage that was it that was the totality i mean the nice things acupuncture
massage nothing wrong there and memorial did some good studies in terms of um acupuncture very valuable
i would say and they have some very fine people i'm not i'm not in any way denigrating the people
they're nice people and they and some of them have done good good work but you couldn't touch anything
that anybody in the establishment of you know any importance had ever said anything negative about
you see that's what it really came down to that if so and so who was the head of the American
Medical Association said that hoxies herbs were crap pardon the expression you couldn't go and even
say you know what we should study those hoxie herbs because maris fishbind or somebody of his of his
equivalent status had already told you that those were worthless why would you want to study that
and and i saw this in action i won't name i'm not going to name names i could but i but i won't
but one of the top officials of the office of alternative medicine which was which they located in
the office of the director of the NIH um he to keep an eye on it and and he was called to a meeting with
the man who was then the director of the NIH and he went in and he was a he's a great guy i'm still in
touch with him this not the not the head of the NIH but the the official at the office of alternative
medicine now the NCCH and in the course of the interview the director of the NIH said well what are
you what do you want to do what are you working on personally what's your interest in what would you
like to you know to study and the guy in without thinking speaking from the heart as you said
said i actually want to do scientific studies of homeopathy and the reaction was so so strong
and so severe like why the hell would you want to study homeopathy you know it's worthless it can't
work it's too diluted blah blah blah the usual party lying about homeopathy and the this official
came back we were having and this is in the midst of our meeting that we were at these we had
we had four to six meetings a year i went i went down to Washington like 30 40 times in part of this
process and he said i think i just did myself out of a job he had a contract like a one year or two
year contract he said i think i just did myself out of a job so what do you mean said um they were
i he told this story and he said they you know i had just had that strong feeling i've never
going to be rehired here he's never worked for the government again the day that his contract was
up was the last day that he ever worked for the government and he's gone on had a glorious career in
in the NGOs and in other other things and he has a he has his own medical practice but that was
literally the kiss of death and they can do that sure they can do that and you nibble you know you're
going to nibble around the edges of this incredibly enormous field of medicine but you'll never get
to be a player in terms of the you know setting policy or being able to move the direction the only
way you can influence this this the hemath is to mobilize public opinion that's the only power
that you have in my this is my experience you know and that's that's unfair to put it my not just
unfair to us as activists or as would be reformers it's unfair to the patients because look you're
asking cancer patients to be the activists who are going to make change and fight for freedom of
choice and all these things they're going through the hardest time in their entire lives and and the
caretakers are going through you know sometimes it's even harder on the care caretakers caretakers
caretakers whatever you want to call them so it's a very difficult situation because the you know
this this juggernaut rolls on and we are just sort of the bystanders and we're yelling out and
saying look this is wrong this is not going the right way you're not doing this right and especially
you know you could use these natural treatments in conjunction with the if you want to in conjunction
with the conventional treatments and there's an abundance of evidence that there's a better outcome
if you do that and you're ignored that's no and and the patients and and believe me fifth
a good 40 50 percent of the patients are asking the doctors can I use supplements or can I do this
or other you know complementary treatments along with these highly toxic destructive treatments
and they they're almost always shut down or this I never hear about people being the whole
heart you know even being treated respectfully it gets to the point where you don't you know
I understand this totally understand this that you don't even want to bring up the topic I don't
bring it up with my own doctors because you know you know you know you're going to be shut down
right and it's it's it's humiliating to be in that situation where you're treated like an idiot
if you if you say but doctor what about if I were to do some intravenous vitamin C for instance now
we have clinical trial data about the effectiveness of vitamin C in one kind of cancer a very difficult
cancer you'll be treated like an idiot I mean the the I hear this from my I do phone consultations
for cancer patients I hear it all the time all the time I never hear maybe that maybe this is
a selection bias going on here but the people come to me I hear horror story after horror story
about how people are treated by the oncologist and and these are lovely the oncologist can be lovely
people but I tell them that's as long as you don't cross them because they are they are nice people
as long as you're doing what they believe to be right okay or even if they don't believe to be
right as long as you do what they tell you to do sure and with the and most of them they are the most
blinded people I know the oncologists are they have blinders on I mean all professions do I think
to a certain degree they are self reinforcing new without a doubt okay and there's also
jealousy they don't want others to poach on what they consider their field they want to have the
men up you know as a group but basically they they don't want to hear anything coming that's not
sanctioned and what does it mean to be sanctioned well there's a whole elaborate structure that's
been created that involves hundreds what thousands of people this is not a little cabal this is a
huge profession gigantic profession their meetings have there 25,000 people in the day in the pre-COVID days
would come to Chicago for the ASCO meeting I mean it's unbelievable event okay but you know basically
it's a it's it's like the poet Philip Larkin said that the what the widest prairies have electric
fences so at the end of that wide fence where everything goes and we can we're intellectuals we can
examine any question you know the BS that you that you hear but there's always an electric fence
at the end that that defines what's acceptable this course you know they they call that the overtune
windows another name for and and so they there's a there's a limit and in my opinion that that
electric fence has been shrinking and shrinking and shrinking over the years they're very they're
very ossified the oncology profession in their beliefs and in what they you know and how they
and how they approach cancer it's very limited they're they're the mental framework that they operate
from the the overtune window some people call that it's it's it's a very small very narrow thing you
know it's everything from you know all the choices from A to B basically right and and so
uh you don't have it you can't break in to that narrow professional circle that asco
american society for clinic oncology and these other groups represent you it's just it's just a
mindset and it reminds me a little bit of um of the church in the late middle ages you know
when when the inquisition inquisition didn't start in the days when the church was ascendant the
inquisition came in when the church was already feeling the pressure of modern science they had
buckled out absolutely absolutely and that's how that's the that's a parallel with the death
the stretcher absolutely worse than death right absolutely so I feel like that's sort of the age we're
in we're in the age where a lot uh you know we're breaking out intellectually from the bounds the
binds of the conventional way of thinking about cancer so much has come out that just threatens to
destroy the conventional uh strictures on on ones thinking about the cancer problem but at the
other hand the controls have never been greater than they are now so it's a it's an immovable force
versus you know a uh an immovable object versus an irresistible force that the force is there it's
going to push through but vis-tremendous amount of of resistance to it as well and um you know I'd
love to say that I you know I'd love to live long enough to see this field of complementary or
integrative oncology triumph I I've seen wonderful things happen but you know there's still tremendous
resistance to it it isn't going to happen so quickly it is in the practice of medicine as a whole
not just oncology I think it's right it more so during this time than anything yes but it does
take and the reason why you're my hero is it takes that those courageous you to stand up and scream
the emperor is not wearing any clothes um when you're gonna get the criticism of your peers and
um general population and the idea now and you're going to get smeared on social media right everywhere
else and canceled on everything and it takes a courageous person to stand up against that and um so
I applaud you thank you and I want to really encourage our listeners we're going to have it up on
this on the screen when we get this video done uh your your website to purchase your books to support
your work it's more support well I'd love to have you out again sometime I know you're a very busy
person I appreciate this I well thank you thank you we'll talk again thank you I appreciate all your
thanks and we'll be back in touch